vous savez l'unité elle est toujours à
faire et après les défaites qu'on a
connu les entation division ont été
fortes
en tout cas dans go j'ai toujours veillé
à ce que chacun puisse avoir un temps de
parole j'ai toujours veillé à ce que
l'on puisse se respecte et qu'on puisse
avoir une grande bienveillance de d1
vis-à-vis des autres et c'est ce que
j'ai dit aux sénateurs je lui indique
quelle est la ligne qu'on peut incarner
politiquement je leur ai dit aussi les
combats notamment sur le territoire
parce que les grands électeurs nous ont
envoyé un message dimanche et la
victoire de dimanche
elle nous oblige maintenant je leur ai
dit qu'on avait trois défis à relever le
premier défi c'est l'unité le
rassemblement parce qu'on est le premier
groupe et croyez-moi si le premier
groupe à se diviser
ça nous irait non seulement groupe et
saluer d'abord au sénat pour avoir une
cohérence il faut pas un sénat j'ai
connu mois la période 2011 2013 2014 où
on avait souvent des cacophonies donc on
a une responsabilité vis-à-vis de
nous-mêmes de notre famille politique
mais surtout surtout surtout vis-à-vis
de l'institution que nous représentons
premier défi entre nous donc c'est le
rassemblement
le deuxième défi c'est un défi un défi
qui touche à la ligne politique il faut
qu'on travaille bien sûr avec la
majorité sénatoriale notamment nos amis
centristes mais surtout par rapport à
l'exécutif on n'a pas se situer par
rapport à mai maquereau ou à d'autres
nous on se situe par rapport à l'intérêt
supérieur du pays
donc on sera à la fois une opposition
intelligente mais en même temps une
force de proposition et je pense que on
doit pas être celui du temps d'avant
mais ceux qui ont un temps d'avancé les
proposer qu'on soit un laboratoire
d'idées qu'on se saisisse de beaucoup de
sujets d'actualité le sujet et
législatives qui vont structurer le
débat public et qu'on ait une position
en amont bien avant que ne tombe
les textes de loi puis enfin le
territoire parce que j'ai été dans un
certain de département pour soutenir nos
candidats jamais jamais je n'ai vu des
élus locaux qui sont autant décourager
qui sont au bord du dépôt de paquetage
en dix ans on n'en peut plus ils ont été
bien sûr choqué par les annonces ce
qu'ils disent a encore plus choqué c'est
le manque de considération qu'un
président de la république dise que il
ya trop d'élus locaux
ça revenait à dire qu'ils étaient
inutiles et en fait tout ce qui ne
résout pas paris c'est eux qui le
portent sur le terrain il trouve ça
injuste
donc ça va être notre combat est sûre ce
combat on sera particulièrement
offensive on ne laissera rien passer
le combat sur les ressources bien sûr
financière
le combat sur la considération le combat
sur les compétences notamment communales
et intercommunales et sur la
représentation
il n'est pas question par exemple
d'adopter une révision de la
constitution qui appauvrit en termes de
représentation la france périphérique
c'est tout un donc on se battra pied à
pied mais on le fera de façon
intelligente et responsable
c'est un avertissement emmanuel macron
quand même se raconte se réformer la
constitution
c'est en tout cas un investissement qui
est claire nous portons nous le messager
grands électeurs de limoges et les
grands électeurs de dimanche
il nous en donnait une victoire mais
cette victoire elle nous oblige nous
sommes fermés à rien je l' ai déjà dit
mais ce ne sera pas un chèque en blanc
et sur la question de l'unité est ce que
la compétition interne dans votre parti
risque pas de faire tanguer aussi en ce
moment on sait qu'il ya des gens qui
sont plus constructif que dans
l'opposition et cetera est-ce que ça
risque pas de faire tanguer le groupe
parlementaire la cette période pour les
républicains de reconstruction et se
choisir un nouveau patron moi j'ai
anticipé les choses et déjà j'avais été
élu il ya trois ans à la veille d'une
élection interne j'avais dit que jamais
le groupe devait être le décalque
parlementaire du parti et est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui j'avais des sénateurs devant
moi qui sont en cours mais qui sont pas
claires donc il peut pas y avoir une
stricte identité entre le mouvement
politique et groupe notre force au sénat
c'est notre indépendance et notre
liberté et j'y veillerai scrupuleusement
je ferai des propositions et je pense
que ça apaisé bien sûr un certain nombre
de craintes que les seins ou les autres
pouvaient avoir
et sur la compétition interne du coup
vous n'êtes pas candidat et vous
shawn rae alors chaque chose en son
temps
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que la
responsabilité je les ai souvent dit de
président de groupe est incompatible
avec la candidature au mouvement donc je
ne serai pas candidat pour l'élection du
mois de décembre prochain et pour le
reste je vous dirai plus tard faibles
étaient présentes ainsi et d'autre et
fab bien sûr bien sûr c'est un signe
l'interprète en tout cas comme un signe
de bonne volonté je crois de part et
d'autre et moi je m'en réjouis
j'ai toujours considéré que la substance
de la vie politique c'est d'essayer de
s'élargir c'est pas de se rétrécir
donc chacun est le bienvenu moi je
respecte les sensibilités
j'ai dit que le groupe n'était ni une
auberge espagnole
mais ni une caserne chacun doit pouvoir
trouver sa place et je veillerai comme
je lé fais scrupuleusement parce que
chacun puisse s'exprimer
puissent avoir accès aux temps de parole
et que la liberté de vote soit une
liberté qui soit vraiment garantit à
chacun sa symbolise aussi un
rassemblement
on n'a pas du tout soutenu les mêmes
candidats aux primaires entre dominique
estrosi
et puis philippe pouillé j'ai voulu s'y
donner un signal puisque l'un est maire
d'une commune rurale l'autre et est élu
de nice d'une grande ville la nouvelle
aquitaine autres paca donc c'est la
complémentarité non seulement politiques
mais en même temps territoriales c'est
un signe en même temps je pense de cette
volonté de renouvellement mais aussi
surtout de rassemblement